okay uh so let's uh do a quick review of
last lecture so last time we started
talking about gyroscopes and uh we
started by basically developing a
mathematical framework that enables us
to study rotations right the physics of
rotating bodies basically specifically
we talked about
um different uh reference frames or
coordinate systems so if you have a
fixed frame s0 and a rotating reference
frame S Sub r with some angular velocity
Vector Omega
then we showed that a given point that
is moving in both reference frames uh um
some point P of T we showed how the time
derivatives of the position are related
in the two reference frames so the time
derivative P dot in the fixed frame is
equal to the time derivative in the
rotating frame plus this extra term
Omega cross P so the vector cross
product of your angular velocity vector
and the position and uh in terms of
physical quantities these are velocities
right so the velocity You observe in the
fixed frame uh is is going to be of
course different from the velocity You
observe if if you're tied to the
rotating frame and this mathematical
expression exactly shows you the
relationship between the two now from
there uh we started looking at the
forces that are observed in the two
reference frames y forces because
inertial sensors as we know measure
forces so that was done by basically
starting from
Newton's law f equals m times a and then
taking uh the the second derivative of
the position so basically taking another
derivative of of this equation and then
we were able to relate the forces and
this is the expression we came up with
that the force in the rotating reference
frame F in Sr is equal to the force in
the fixed frame plus three additional
terms the first one is called the
Coriolis force and it's given by this
expression minus 2m Omega cross P dot so
it's proportional to the angular
velocity of the of the rotating frame
and the velocity of the particle in the
rotating frame P Dot
there's the centrifugal force which is
given by this expression minus M Omega
cross Omega cross P so it is
proportional in a way to the position of
of the particle and the square of the of
the angular velocity and finally you
have your Euler Force which is given by
this expression minus M Omega dot cross
P so it's proportional to the position
of the particle and its angular
acceleration right so this is Omega dot
here
um and specifically we said the type of
accelerometer that we're going to study
in detail which is a vibratory
mechanical accelerometer essentially
measures the Coriolis force or the
Coriolis acceleration so this F divided
by m that would be your Aquarius
acceleration and that or the magnitude
of of that acceleration a a coriolis is
going to be directly proportional to the
angular velocity
and also proportional to of course the
linear velocity of the of the of the
particle so if the linear velocity is
known and you can measure the Coriolis
acceleration you basically write this
simple equation you can find out what
the angular velocity uh was and this is
the the principle of operation of the
type of
gyroscope that we're going to study in
detail
so essentially with with all the maths
that we developed and the physics that
we did on top of it and we basically got
to this point
um this is something very actionable
because it essentially tells us that if
we can build a very specific type of
accelerometer that can measure coriolis
acceleration by doing this simple math
you can essentially make it a gyroscope
right so the gyroscope or this specific
type of gyroscope you're studying down
the hood it's it's really an
accelerometer but it's measuring a very
specific type of acceleration which is a
coriolis acceleration and then that can
be easily converted to angular velocity
right
okay and then we started uh looking at
essentially the the the mechanical
architecture of of this type of
accelerometer given uh in in this figure
here so inside the device and this is a
one-dimensional one
um so it is going to measure uh angular
velocities uh that are uh with respect
to the axis that is going in and out of
the plane so this orange
arrow here shows you the direction of
the the rotation or the angular velocity
that the device will measure
and internal to the device it's again a
damped spring Mass system which
shouldn't be a surprise because we said
down the hood this is really an
accelerometer right but it's going to
measure a very specific type of
acceleration and the way that is
achieved basically it has uh two uh axes
of of motion that are perpendicular to
each other one is called the drive Axis
or the or the drive direction also
called the primary mode of the of the
device and in this axis call that x sub
r
we basically actively Drive the the uh
this harmonic oscillator with some drive
force F sub D okay so that force is
generated internally in the device with
some actuation mechanism that we'll talk
about
so if that so that force is going to
cause some movement in the XR direction
right and then on top of that if you
have some angular motion or angular
velocity uh with uh in
uh in in Omega what happens is that the
two will generate a coriolis
acceleration in the perpendicular
Direction which we call Y sub R and
that's called the secondary mode or the
sense Direction okay let's make sure
this this makes sense so if I go
um here to the to the projector again uh
you're gonna have your primary mode
generating velocity in this direction in
x r and then you have your uh angular
velocity that we want to sense defined
by Omega coming out of the plane so as
we know the Coriolis acceleration is
given or the vector is given by Omega
cross the the linear velocity right so
linear velocity is in X Direction
Omega is out of the plane you do your
right hand rule so the Coriolis
acceleration is going to be in the Y sub
R Direction so so then I think
everything should make sense so now we
have this accelerometer in the sense
Direction and the acceleration that it
would sense is going to be the Coriolis
acceleration so we measure that
acceleration and then with some simple
math we should be able to in principle
find find Omega does this uh make sense
okay so now we're gonna essentially
analyze this you know write all the
equations and derive the the full you
know uh
mathematical analysis of it uh but I I
would really want to ask you to after
class at some point really you know
um study this there's a lot packed in
this simple diagram and
um you know we started with some
abstract mathematical framework of you
know framing reference rotating frames
of reference and fixed frames of
reference and then we drive these uh
pseudo forces or fictitious forces and
and then we kind of get to this point
that uh we have we have we have a
mechanical architecture for a gyroscope
but really I think the
the the really clever the genius idea
behind uh how how this type of gyroscope
works it's all packed in this figure you
know it really takes a lot of creativity
to to to to take a very abstract
mathematical or physical idea something
like the Coriolis effect and really get
something useful and actionable like a
sensor out of it and and that's really
the type of
um you know creativity that requires a
deep understanding of the mathematics
and physics and also the requirements of
of sensors and really you know bridge
the gap there and design something from
first principles so so really make sure
to spend some time because uh there is
there is a lot really happening in this
in this diagram and I don't mean just
you know just the math or just a physics
really think about you know somebody
came up with this and what was that
thought process that goes from something
very back like the math on that board to
something very practical which is which
is this design and and I think that's a
very uh interesting thought experiment
uh for you okay so let's uh let's look
at the the physics of it then so
essentially we have two independent
spring Mass systems uh in in this device
and for each of them we can write the
force equations so
uh let's uh first write the equation for
the drive Direction so the total
inertial force in the X direction or X
of R Direction which is our drive is is
mass times acceleration and everything
here we are writing our equations all in
the internal reference frame of the
device right so this is everything is is
internal to the device right now so mass
times acceleration and it's the sum of
three forces right you have your spring
Force you have your dampening and you
have your dry Force which is actively
generated inside inside the device right
so uh what about the sense Direction the
sense Direction the force in the sense
direction is the mass times the
acceleration in y sub R and that also is
the sum of three components you have
your spring Force you have your
dampening force and you have the
Coriolis Force right so so really this
third term is what differentiates the
force in this drive Direction with the
force and the in the Sanskrit Direction
now uh essentially we can plug in
expressions for for all of all of these
terms right so
uh for let's do the the spring and
dampening uh Expressions first we just
like the case of accelerometer go with
the simple uh you know linear models for
the spring with the hooke's law and a
linear damping Factor uh with some uh a
constant B so then the primary mode
equation uh becomes this uh X double dot
plus b over m x so that's the dampening
term uh plus KX over m x r that's the
that's the spring term equals F sub D
over M and F sub D is the again it's the
active force that you're we're driving
the mass with and your secondary mode
becomes essentially the left hand side
is the same so you get like y double dot
and then you get your dampening term and
you get your spring term and then the
right hand side this minus 2 Omega x dot
this is the uh the the coriolister right
this is that that Omega cross XR what
happened to the vector cross product
well here we can simplify it because we
can we're writing equations separately
in X and Y axes and we know that by
design of of this device
Omega and X are are perpendicular right
so Omega is out of plane X the the mass
movement is restricted to the plane so
when you do the cross product that's
sine Theta term becomes one right that's
sine of 90 degrees okay so let's
actually write it down to make sure it's
uh it's it's uh it's clear so the actual
coriolis term is
Omega cross essentially the
x dot right but this is the x dot Vector
right the actual movement of the of the
of the of the proof Mass but the
magnitude of it basically becomes
magnitude
Omega
magnitude x dot sine Theta that's the
magnitude of your Coriolis effect
there's like a factor of two also here
but I'm just I'm just looking at the at
the cross product for now and then to
simplify the math we have uh instead of
like Norm Omega we're just writing that
as Omega so that's just a notational
thing but this sine Theta becomes one
because Theta is 90 degrees
by Design and then uh your velocity is
is just this x x dot R right so that's
that's what the Coriolis term is we've
just uh
um simplified the math there okay
so let's solve it and to solve it of
course we need to decide how to what
what deriving Force we need to generate
inside the device how are we going to
drive this uh
um proof mass and the way it's uh driven
uh um and that's why these devices are
called vibratory uh uh gyroscopes is
that the driving force is is a harmonic
term so it's just some F0 times e to the
J
Omega D times D so Omega D is the is the
driving frequency and you just generate
the sinusoidal drive force uh to to move
the mass again this is not just if you
remember when we were doing
accelerometers we said the external
Force first we started with just a pure
harmonic term and then we generalized it
using the the the the Fourier theorem to
any any time domain waveform here the
device is generating this and it's
always just a pure sine wave right so
here we are not doing like a
simplification or you know like an
isolated analysis this is the waveform
that the device actually generates it's
just a pure sine wave okay
so we plug that in and uh we can first
solve the Dynamics in the in the drive
axis so our x sub R exactly like we
solved a case of the accelerometer
becomes basically this expression here
which is a 0 over this should be very
familiar from the analysis of the
accelerometer you have some omega 0
squared minus Omega Drive squared plus
JB Omega D over M times the the same
basically complex exponential term so
you can just write that this is this is
a constant right a0 is just your F 0
over over the mass and then the Omega 0
x is just KX over M so it's the spring
constant and the X Direction Over M and
Omega D is again known that's the the
drive frequency of the device so all of
this you can just lump it into some x0
so your Dynamics in the drive is just a
pure harmonic with some x0 e to the J
Omega DT now we can plug this x r into
the second equation for the sense axis
and find our displacement in the sense
direction right so we start again with
knowing the fact that because it's a
linear dynamical system and we are
driving it with a
essentially a pure harmonic with
frequency Omega D the response y r is
also going to be some y 0 e to the J
Omega DT plug that into the equation so
you plug this for y and this X or this
expression for x and after just some
straightforward math again we are
solving another accelerometer equation
right you get this
so you get y 0 times this term which
again should be familiar Omega 0y
squared minus Omega D squared plus J B
Omega D over M times our complex
exponential equals this thing on the
right hand side that's just minus 2
Omega x r dot right so what this guy is
is minus 2
Omega
x dot R so x dot R if you differentiate
this you get a j Omega D term and you
have the x0 and that's what what that is
okay so uh let's find our displacement
in the sense and Direction so
um
what the displacement becomes from this
you just basically divide both sides by
this term and your expression for
your sense displacement is given by by
this expression here what you can do is
also plug in for x0 this expression on
top so remember this here
is our x0
plug that into here then you get this
big ugly equation down below okay
there's a lot in here but if you inspect
it carefully
everything in this big fraction this is
just one constant
right everything in Here is known to us
we know a zero that's just our the our
F0 which is the drive force over M we
know Omega D that's our dry frequency
Omega 0x and Omega 0 y these are known
by uh the fact that we know the value of
the proof mass and the spring constants
BX and b y are just dampening factors so
all of this is just one constant right e
to the J Omega DT that's also a complex
exponential with a known frequency the
thing that really really matters here is
this little Omega that you can almost
miss it if you don't look for it right
so what is essentially the key here is
that the displacement in the sense
direction is directly proportional to
the angular velocity that we are trying
to measure so we did actually build a
gyroscope right it is doing what it's
supposed to do so your secondary
displacement is proportional to the
angular velocity
Omega again the math gets a little you
know messy but at the end of the day all
of this is just one big constant you
just plug in numbers into it and that's
essentially kind of like the sensitivity
of your of your device right so if you
want a good sensor right you want it to
give you a large response for a a small
um you know value of Omega right you
want your response to be large and
strong so that means you want this
Factor here
to be large right you want this to be
large because that's essentially like
the sensitivity of your of your device
right so if you want this to be large
how do you make this large uh you you
make the nominator uh
that the numerator large and the
denominator is small right if you start
with the denominator look at these terms
you have omega 0 x squared minus Omega D
Squared Omega 0 y squared minus Omega D
Squared so how about we start with
making these terms zero right that makes
the denominator small should help with
the with the sensitivity so to maximize
your sensitivity essentially what you do
is you you uh pick your values of your
spring constant and the masses and the
mass such that and also you're driving
uh frequency Omega D such that both your
primary and secondary modes are driven
at resonance right and by that we mean
you can pick the same spring constant in
the X and Y directions call that K and
with that then your Omega 0x and Omega
0y become the same they were both equal
to square root of K Over M call that
Omega 0 and then if you pick your Omega
D again remember you're free to choose
your Omega D that's your drive frequency
if you also choose your Omega D to be
equal to Omega 0 then if you go back to
the previous expression this term
becomes zero and this term also becomes
zero that's going to help with
sensitivity right you make your this
multiplicative Factor large
okay so then also your math simplifies a
lot a lot of again the terms become just
zero and you plug in these values to the
to the a big expression from the slide
before and it just becomes this much
more simpler expression so your
displacement in the sense Direction
becomes 2 j m f 0 times BX times b y
Omega 0 e to the J Omega T so now
essentially this term here is your
sensitivity right
and again by making these choices for X
for k x k y and Omega D we are
maximizing our our sensitivity we're
getting a larger response okay
what matters at the end of the day is
exactly like the case of the
accelerometer you measure uh
capacitively as we'll see the amplitude
of this secondary motion and the
amplitude of this again this uh e to the
J Omega DT term
goes away and that's your basically
amplitude response right so it's just
some sensitivity Factor times the
angular uh
um angular velocity
Omega
or
basically that's that's the sensitivity
another thing that as you can see from
this expression helps with the
sensitivity is for your dampening
factors to be small right so typically
gyroscopes are designed to be
underdamped so small bees right
unlike the the case where for
accelerometers that under damping can
cause issues like
slow
responses due to oscillations in the
transient response for gyroscopes we are
driving them at resonance right so the
thing is always vibrating and because
the amplitude of the response is given
by this expression having a small B
meaning under damping it helps in the
case of a gyroscope why not
just remove damping altogether make make
b0 or as close to zero as possible is
that a good choice yeah any thoughts
too sensitive like then you can't
measure it essentially yes I mean too
sensitive is is not necessarily bad but
well first in in practice we can never
have zero dampening right just just by
you know natural frictions and things
like that there's always some nuns Ruby
so zero wouldn't even be practically
possible but also you don't want it to
want to make these as small as possible
because uh it can cause inner stability
issues so if your bees are very small
the amplitude of the oscillations can
can grow and your proof mask can for
instance crash into the walls of the
device and and you know cause really
stability issues so that's why you want
some damping but you always under damp
it um so so you get a you get a nice
large sensitivity out of this okay so so
that's that's in summary exactly uh what
we said we know what the response of the
or the sensitivity of the of the
[Music]
gyroscope is also from this expression
um again to get a largest possible
sensitivity having a larger proof Mass
helps okay for gyroscopes remember for
um accelerometers it didn't matter for
sensitivity what the proof Mass value
was but for gyroscope it actually having
a large
um helps as as you can see in this
expression you also want a nice large
driving force
um if possible
Omega zero I mean from mathematically it
seems like smaller is better but
remember Omega 0 also determines the
bandwidth of your device so usually you
don't have much of a choice for it it's
kind of dictated by the by the
application
okay so let's talk about uh the
actuation right so we need to for
gyroscopes we need to derive the mass
and generate some actuator actuation
force and let's see how that is
generated
uh in these types of devices it's
generated using electrostatic actuators
and these are also just capacitors
basically
uh so let's start with a case of a
simple parallel plate capacitor so you
have your two plates
with some voltage v0 applied across and
some uh separation between the two so as
we know there's going to be some charge
build up
for the amount of Q and uh the your your
your charge the voltage applied and the
capacitance there is a simple linear
relationship between the between the
three quantities so if you apply a
voltage v0 to a parallel plate capacitor
of capacitor and C the charge is going
to be q0 equals c times v0 okay what
about the energy stored in the in the
capacitor so just by this process of the
build up of the charge you're you're
storing some energy in your capacitor
and the energy can be calculated by just
the integral of the of the charge Q
times DV from 0 to whatever your final
voltage is so so essentially you're
starting at zero voltage and slowly
ramping up the voltage across the
capacitor and that charge build up with
this integral gives you the total energy
that that you have in your capacitor you
plug in your charge and voltage
relationship so for Q you can substitute
c times V and then you carry out the
integral you get the famous expression
of one-half c times V 0 squared which is
the total energy in a capacitor or you
can write it in terms of the charge so
it's one half q zero squared over C okay
so that's the total energy in a parallel
plate capacitor but you're not
interested in energy we want to find
force right how how much force can you
generate with with it with a capacitor
in in an electrostatic manner Okay so
let's assume that in this parallel plate
capacitor one of the plates let's say
the top plate can move right
um you let it move up and down and with
that now we can talk about forces right
so there's going to be some
electrostatic force F that attracts the
two planes okay and if you have some
small movement of the top plate by some
DX what happens is that the movement
consumes some mechanical mechanical
energy and as we know that the energy
the mechanical energy is the force times
movement that's the amount of mechanical
work that you do by moving that top
plate by a small amount so you have FDX
that's your mechanical energy but by
essentially a conservation of energy we
know that that should equal the amount
of electromagnetic energy that you lose
right so you convert some of the stored
electromagnetic energy in your capacitor
to Mechanical work by letting the top
plate move with the electrostatic force
right so the conservation of energy
essentially gives you FDX again that's
the mechanical energy plus d e which is
the change in the in the electrostatic
energy should equal to zero right now
with this we can now find we're
interested in the force we're interested
in how much force you can generate
electrostatically so F just becomes the
minus the dedx which is the derivative
of your electrostatic energy with
respect to the spacing between the two
plates of the capacitor and for E if you
can plug in the expression we just
derived in the in the previous slide
which was one half q zero squared times
one over C
so essentially you need to take the
derivative of 1 over C or you can write
it in terms of voltage and then your
Force becomes one half V 0 squared DC DX
so the derivative of the capacitance
with respect to X so to find the force
essentially we need this DC DX term
which is dependent on the geometry of
the capacitor right we need to know the
exact geometry to be able to take the
derivative of it with respect to X and
then find force now we start with the
simple parallel plate capacitor but the
actual geometries that are used in mems
devices
are essentially comb Drive actuators so
so these are kind of like the same
structure as that we use for sensing
these comb structures are also used for
for actuation but the the high level
idea is the same so you have your black
is your fixed electrode it has these
fingers and then the blue is you're
moving and then by the electrostatic
force that you generate the top one can
move up and down with respect to the to
the bottom one it has a simple geometry
that we can
uh basically analyze analytically
essentially what you have is uh between
every two plates you have some
capacitance right so you have
capacitance here capacitance here
capacitance here and so on and each of
these you can approximate by a parallel
plate capacitor so it's kind of like you
have n parallel plate capacitors side by
side right and we know how what the
capacitance of a parallel plate is so
for a parallel plate
capacitor C is
Epsilon zero a over D is that okay thank
you section so it's proportional to the
area of the plates and inversely
proportional to D which is the gap
between the two plates times the
primitivity of of vacuum
um so using that essentially what we
have here is say there is n of of these
gaps between the fingers so you get a
factor of n the area a between the
plates is equal to essentially it's it's
a two-dimensional so I assume it's it's
going in and out of the plane right uh
um plane of this slide and then this
area a becomes what the dimensions
defined here it becomes x0 minus X so
that's the basically the length of the
overlap between the two fingers times
the height of it and the height is not
shown in this picture because it's 2D
but assume it's kind of like extruded
out of the plane and that's H so H times
x0 minus a that is our essentially
area right of the capacitive uh plates D
is the gap okay so over D times Epsilon
zero and N is how many of these you have
and that gives you your total
capacitance right so very easy to
analyze uh in that regard now uh if we
just take the derivative of this C with
respect to X and plug it into the
previous equation we had that gives us a
total actuation Force basically what's
very nice about this is you see it's a
linear function of X so if you take the
derivative you just get a constant right
let's do it together so what is DC DX
here DC DX
is equal to so we get H over d k is over
and we get n and we get Epsilon zero
right that's it with a minus sign
so that's our DC DX basically plug that
into
um
the previous equation basically this
equation for force and we get the total
actuation force that you get with a comb
Drive actuator yes
uh so the area is H times the X naught
minus X does that mean that there's like
absolutely no influence from
from any of the
you mean from these areas yeah yeah
that's a great question so uh basically
the question is I'm I'm going to
reformulate your question but I think
the gist of this is what about the
capacitances from these portions right
essentially there is uh capacitances
here right and here and we're kind of
ignoring those and uh you're absolutely
right there's a little bit of
capacitance added but if you if if by
Design uh you make the this this length
here so if you make this length much
much much longer than than this
Dimension here uh then essentially the
contribution from these parts doesn't
matter and and you can ignore it right
but but you're absolutely right there's
a little bit of capacitance added from
you know the it's it's not a perfect
parallel plate but it's so close
especially if you make your your aspect
ratio much longer than what I've drawn
here that then that that part can be
ignored okay
so we plug that in and then we get our
full expression for our actuation Force
which is equal to negative one-half n
times H over D so so all this here is
just the geometric uh constant right n
is the number of plates H is the the gap
between uh sorry H is the height D is
the gap Epsilon zero is the permittivity
and then V zero squared is your drive
voltage or the amplitude of the of the
drive voltage that you put on the
capacitor what's really really nice and
useful about this design is that the
force that you get again it's constant
so it's independent of how much the the
plates have moved and that really helps
in the in the analysis of the of the
gyroscope and also when it comes to
calculating angular velocity the fact
that you have a constant force really
really helps so this is a very nice
practical geometry for actuation and
that's why it's used a lot
and what you do in practice is
um you you again as as we said you want
to drive your proof Mass with uh like a
pure harmonic at a constant frequency
Omega zero and as you see your force is
proportional to v0 squared so you just
apply a voltage a Time varying voltage
across this chrome Drive capacitor uh or
Com Drive actuator which is some v0
times e to the J one half Omega t y one
half because the force is proportional
to the square of the voltage as you see
here so you you generate a voltage as at
half your uh Drive uh frequency that you
want and then the force becomes this uh
pure harmonic which is a bunch of
constant some geometric constants and
some v0 squared times e to the J Omega T
right so that's how you derive drive
your your mass at at resonance in this
so our analysis is now essentially
complete if you remember when we if you
slice back we uh we derived this
expression for sensitivity of the
gyroscope but we didn't say what F0 was
right there your drive force now we have
an expression for F0 so essentially your
F0 with this comb Drive structure driven
with a pure hormone demonic is given by
this expression here which is NH over D
times minus one half Epsilon zero V 0
squared plug everything in and this is
your final expression for the
sensitivity of your
vibratory gyroscope and and with this
again you have everything right all of
these are are either design parameters
that you can choose or otherwise known
parameters again we want to maximize
this to get the best sensitivity so good
choices you can make as we said choose
your BX and b y small so under damp it
choose your M large large mass right
large n and large H so that's just you
know maximize the capacitance of your
Chrome Drive actuators by either
increasing the number of plates or
decreasing the gap between them or
increasing the height between them or
decreasing D which is the gap between
the actuators uh plates or do all of
these together together and also derive
it with a large voltage also helps with
with the sensitivity so again when it
comes to like mems Engineers who are
designing these devices these are all
design parameters that they can go and
optimize yes
like no one concerned about like
dividing by a really small number
because everyone like linear algebra we
need to divide by a school number it's
like unstable that's a great question so
uh the question is we have a bunch of
parameters in the denominator here and
is there a concern of like if dividing
by very small numbers causing
instabilities or or other issues and
your your uh exactly right like
specifically when it comes to these
dampening factors you don't want them to
be too small because it can even
mechanically not just mathematically
like dealing with large numbers but
these large numbers are tied to physical
quantities right like a very small B
here it's just not a small number in in
our math it means for instance that the
um the the masses is vibrating inside
the device and a small b means the
amplitude of the vibrations is going to
grow larger and larger and larger and at
some point it can become so large that
your proof Mass physically crashes the
internal walls of your device and and it
can cause damage okay
okay very good so so again yeah these
are all design parameters but
these are it's not just yeah go go make
your denominator as small as possible or
your numerator as as large as possible
there's a trade space always so as you
make your M large it can cause other
issues it can cause non-linearities or
other things or
um or or are very practical fabrication
issues so that's why the design
Engineers really need to understand the
process on one side and understand the
system level you know metrics like this
on the other side and then go optimize
the the design of the device for the
specific application
in mind okay let's look at some
actual pictures of these men's devices
here's a
again high level you know diagram of how
these devices work and this is the case
of a 1D gyroscope this should be pretty
familiar right you have your proof Mass
with some Springs anchored to basically
the Silicon wafer and the the red uh
capacitor capacitive Place those are
your actuators so
um those generate the
harmonic motion in the in the in the
drive direction and then you have your
green blue sense capacitors on the two
sides and then when the device when the
proof Mass moves up and down uh due to
the Coriolis acceleration that's going
to get picked up by the sense capacitors
um something very interesting here is
that the design is such that as the mass
moves left and right in the XR Direction
there is no net change in the
capacitance sensed by your sense
capacitors which is this blue green
capacitors because when it goes left
right you're going to get reduced
capacitance on one side and increase it
on the other side so the net change is
zero so you're insensitive to the
movement that you're generating in XR
but if it goes up down then the
capacitances on both sides are going to
change in the same way either go up or
down and that's how you you that's why
you're sensitive to Y movement but
you're insensitive to to X movement when
it comes to picking things up and then
dampening exactly like accelerometers is
is uh achieved in these men's devices by
some inert gas in a sealed chamber and
and viscous uh viscous dampening
one picture of uh one axis men's
gyroscope I think by now you should be
able to fully explain what's what's
happening here right so you have your
proof Mass the what's highlighted in red
is your combat traders to generate the
the the the drive motion and in this
axis so the Mass is like constantly
vibrating at some frequency Omega D in
this axis and then in green you have
your sense capacitor so as soon as there
is some rotation uh about an axis that
is perpendicular to the plane of the
device what happens is that that
rotation plus the actuation in this axis
together generate a coriolis
acceleration in the perpendicular
Direction and that is going to be picked
up by the capacitive sensors that are
highlighted in green and then these are
the actual you know um electron
microscope images of the actual
fabricated device so you see the your
sense capacitors up there and this I
think is the comb Drive yes that's the
comb Drive actuator and these are the
capacitive sense plates that that you
have yes
system need
two green capacities so I can't just
have one on one side great question so
why do we have two two green sense
capacitors on both sides there's there's
two reasons for it one is more signal
right you always want to get as much
signal as as you can
um so if there is you know some surface
or area available to add more capacitive
sense uh uh sensors you would do that
but also
um uh because of the thing we were
talking about here if you don't put one
of these right just remove one side okay
then what happens is that as you
generate your drive the mass is going to
move to the left and right right then
you get a net non-zero change of
capacitance on one side which means you
would couple your drive movement to what
you want to sense which is the the
Coriolis acceleration right so it just
the device wouldn't even function you
cannot decouple them from from the
perspective of your capacitive sensor
it's going to be sensitive to both
movement in X and in y direction and
that's not desired you want your
capacitor to only respond to movement in
the drive axis which is due to coriolis
acceleration when you put it on both
sides when it goes left and right one
side is going to lose capacitance the
other side is going to gain capacitance
right so there's a net zero change in
capacitance on both sides and that means
you're insensitive to horizontal motion
you're only sensitive to up down motion
which is the motion you want to sense
okay so that's that's also very so it's
not just to get more signal that's nice
but also practically if you remove one
of these your device wouldn't function
because it's it's it's going to respond
to both your drive movement and the
Coriolis movement which is not desired
does that make sense
okay
um
one more picture to look at are our
favorite iPhone example iPhone 4 so if
remember for the accelerometer we looked
at this this device tiny one right here
there is another one right next to it
and and that's the gyroscope
and then uh it's actually a three axis
men's gyroscope fascinating design I I
really really highly encourage you to
just like look at this picture and make
sure you know every piece of it uh makes
sense there's really a lot going uh on
in here uh because it's it's basically
just four proof masses moving into axes
but you can with those sense uh uh
angular velocity in all three axes
um I mean just visually you know just
the the fact that like it's such an
intricate you know design of mems apart
I think at a system level uh you should
be able to really understand you know
how the movement of these masses is
related to
um
uh two different angular velocities that
you can apply to the device let's just
and it's and it's um the men's structure
is in two layers so there's the bottom
layer which has these big capacitive
plates for sensing pitch and roll and
then the top layer has the proof masses
with the comb drives and also some
capacitive fingers for sensing here
um if we just zoom into the to the top
layer of the memsa structure that's this
and everything is kind of like
highlighted in different colors
uh one thing to note I think I forgot to
uh um put it down here what is called
pitch proof mask this is for pitch and
yaw so these two green masses uh with
their movement enable the device to
essentially move both pitch and yaw uh
and then you have your your row you have
your comb drives there's a bunch of
Springs of course because these masses
need to vibrate and then you have your
your sense plates so um just to
understand that the Dynamics of of these
masses I think this picture really helps
um so first again you have four proof
masses in the device these kind of like
trapezoidal looking things and two of
them M1 and M3 are are moving in this
direction right and then M4 and M2 are
moving in the perpendicular Direction
and knowing that then you can
think of different angular velocities in
three different axes and then that tells
you combined with the axes of motion of
of or vibration of these proof masses
that tells you what kind of Dynamics you
expect from different angular velocities
so let's do I'll do one of them with you
and then I'll let you do the other two
by myself so if if you apply a yaw so a
yaw is a rotation across the z-axis
right so perpendicular to the to the
plane of the masses right so that's your
Omega axis and how does that affect
let's say an M4 and M2 right so M4 and
M2 and I'm going to go on the board here
so m4m2 are are moving in this direction
and then that's Z is the axis of of your
Omega so you do Omega cross the linear
velocity of these two masses so so I'm
Omega across that and then my my thumb
is pointing in the direction of the
Coriolis acceleration so the Coriolis
acceleration due to yaw is going to move
M4 and M2 in the direction shown by
these yellow uh uh red arrows right and
with that if you put
capacitive sense plates
accordingly then you can pick up yeah
and if you go to the previous picture
here you see that's why your yaw senses
the capacitive fingers are placed there
because uh the the Coriolis acceleration
from yaw is going to
move
the masses so that's going to be from
your right
and then it's going to be picked up by
these yaw sense
basically plates so make sure you really
fully analyze this and and everything
should should make sense to you as you
kind of like look at the look at the
men's structure here any questions
okay so I have a question for you and my
question is
if I go back to
where we started with the mechanical
architecture of the accelerometer if I
go
so now we fully know
you know we even looked at the men's
structure and everything and I hope
you're convinced that this is a proper
gyroscope
now my question is uh if if we didn't
know about gyroscopes yet and I showed
this to you and asked you what do you
think this is you would probably say an
accelerometer right it's just a spring
Mass down to Spring Mass system in two
different axis so you might have said
it's probably like a two axis
accelerometer right and it is a two axis
accelerometer right like if externally I
apply acceleration in this direction or
in that direction to the device it's
gonna through the spring couple to the
mass and cause you know the mass to move
around right and there's always going to
be external accelerations so how does
this device properly function if it's
also sensitive to linear acceleration
that's applied to it externally
is that does the question make sense
like I I argued for like a good hour
that or so that this is a proper
gyroscope
but I could argue also that this is a
two axis accelerometer and if both of
these are coupled and picked up
by the device
how does it function how can it tell
angular
velocity from linear acceleration
anyone
okay so so the answer is kind of kind of
like there's there's two very clever
things in the design that that helps the
device
um basically differentiate or only be
sensitive to uh um angular motion and
not linear acceleration well first thing
is that you cannot fully decouple so so
there is going to be a little bit of
coupling from external linear
acceleration to the device and it's
going to look like a little bit of added
noise if there's external acceleration
in blood
but most of it you can fully filter out
by two things one is remember this F sub
d
uh we generated
right and it's going to be driven at a
very specific frequency right you pick
your Omega D and that's the resonance
frequency of the device and your
response in the sense direction is also
going to be exactly at that frequency so
just by some filtering operation if you
only look at the response at Omega d
right if you do like a sharp and best
filter and only look at that resonant
frequency uh that's going to already
filter out a lot of external
acceleration that you can apply because
it's probably going to be wide band and
you know we're completely out of pen so
so that's one right you only look at the
frequency that you're driving it at and
that's gonna and filter everything else
out
um now having said that it means that if
somebody somehow knows what the drive
frequency of your gyroscope is
they can kind of
distractively attack it so they can
generate for instance acoustic waves at
that exact frequency and couplet to your
device if they know the resonant
frequency and then they can really
really disrupt the performance of your
device if they actually externally
couple
accelerations at that frequency this the
second thing that helps you is if I go
to
um
this last picture we looked at and this
one is very dependent on the
architecture of the device but for this
one specifically for instance if we go
back to let me do it on the iPad here if
we go back to how for instance our yaw
affects the what kind of coriolis
acceleration it generates under two
masses you would see that
from
yah the two masses are gonna experience
coriolis acceleration in different
directions right and that's why these
arrows are colored because the reds are
pointing to opposite directions as you
apply angular velocity one of the masses
for instance it's gonna depending on the
direction of your Omega one of them is
going to experience a coriolis
acceleration in say
Northwest Direction the other one is
going to experience it in southeast
direction or something like that if it
makes sense right so the two masses are
going to go in opposite directions again
it's going to be either like this or
like that so the signals that your
capacitive sensors are going to pick up
are going to be having opposite signs if
it's coming from a rotational motion but
they're going to have the same sign if
it's coming from a linear acceleration
that's another very clever thing that by
Design lets you decouple rotation from
linear acceleration
make sense
okay so there's two things right there's
filtering just look at Omega D and also
by design of the device maybe you can
look at the signs of things if they're
opposite signs or the same sign and that
helps you decouple
okay uh let's also talk a little bit
about excuse me um noise and resolution
in uh gyroscopes
um I'm not again going to go into the
detail of the fluctuation dissipation
theorem and all that you can read about
it
but the main takeaway is that you can
just like the case of accelerometers
come up with
um
uh uh analytical expressions for the
variance or the standard deviation of
the noise that accelerometers experience
and these are again due to Thermal
effects right so thermal effects calls
these random vibrations of the proof
mass and they are going to show up as
some random
angular velocities in the device the
expression for
um
RMS value or the standard deviation of
the noise is given by this so
high level takeaway for us is typically
a angular velocities that are less than
a standard deviation of noise they're
not going to be
measurable right they're just like below
noise flow in some more sensitive
applications you might require things to
be like above two or three or four Sigma
to to declare them uh detectable right
and then if you look at the noise
variance or standard deviation uh it's
proportional to a number of things of
course them the measurement bandwidth
Delta f is there you have the
temperature you have the voltsman
constant but the damping factor is in
there right so smaller damping factors
also help with reducing the noise in the
device right another reason to have
these devices under damped is also
inversely proportional to mass
displacement in the primary Direction
and The resonance frequency of the
device so if those parameters are large
it will also help with reducing the
noise that the device picks up so again
these go into design trade-offs as it
comes to designing the actual memsa
structure for these devices
if you look at the data sheets of actual
devices they typically give you you know
noise curves
and what's very interesting to note here
is that this is one from Analog Devices
and they give two different noise scares
with vibration and without vibration and
the reason as as you see with vibration
you're almost
a little less than 10x but almost 10x
more noise right an order of magnitude
more noise and it's exactly because of
what we talked about because linear
accelerations at least a little bit of
it will couple into the the
gyroscope and will show up as effective
noise basically and that's why with
vibration you get more noise than
without vibration and this device has a
resonance frequency of about about one
kilohertz
um any questions
okay let's continue so we basically
finished
um
the the discussion of accelerometers and
gyroscopes uh we know the physics of the
devices we did a system level analysis
we also looked at some actual you know
fabrication details
um one thing to note is that for both
the accelerometer and the gyroscope uh
we picked a very specific type of these
devices which was the mems devices there
are other types of exonometers and
gyroscopes as we said like Optical
gyroscopes for instance that work on
different physics principles
but the types that we covered these are
most common ones and most useful ones
for robotic applications and that's why
we covered this time now here there's
one more
um piece in this chapter uh that that I
want to talk about but before that
really quickly just like the case of uh
the accelerometer you can also write a
measurement model for a gyroscope and it
looks exactly like what an accelerometer
measurement model is so essentially you
have your true underlying angular
velocities Omega and there is going to
be some noise added to it Omega n and
these are appear in the most General
case vectors in R3 right if you have a
three axis device so you have omega plus
Omega n that's being multiplied by this
three by three Matrix which models 2fx
for you right a crosstalk and
sensitivity variations in different axes
so your diagonal entries of your M which
we call Alphas those are sensitivity
errors ideally you want them to be all
one but in practice there's going to be
some deviation and then the off diagonal
the Capas are your uh crosstalk
basically terms so that's when angular
velocity from one axis couples and shows
up as angular velocity in a different
axis and then you also always have a
bias term beta which is just a constant
Vector added
these devices are typically well
calibrated so your your m is is is
almost identical to almost the identity
if it's a well-calibrated device that's
that's what you get so there's almost no
crosstalk and almost no gainers but but
I mean in practice it's it's it's never
exactly identity there's always a little
bit of residual miscalibration
noise is noise nothing we can do about
that and there's also always a little
bit of residual bias and device data
sheets actually give you these
parameters so they tell you for instance
how much crosstalk you should expect in
the worst case or how much bias you
should expect from your device so these
are parameters that if you're simulating
the performance of your sensor you can
actually read them from a data sheet and
and plug in the numbers
okay
now we're gonna uh talk about so we know
how these sensors works the
accelerometer and the gyroscope
um and uh by the way these days uh you
can buy chips that uh are both devices
integrated into one because these are
both built on mems processes so now in
the case of for instance iPhone 4 you
should you saw there were two separate
chips for accelometer and gyroscope uh
newer phones it's just one chip and it's
both integrated into into one die in
fact there's also a third sensor that
these days is is integrated which is a
magnetometer and that's kind of like a
like a magnetic field sensor that acts
like a digital compass if you will we
didn't talk about it but you will see it
in the homework or maybe you've already
seen it in the homework it's not an
inertial sensor it's a different kind of
a sensor but that is also integrated so
if you see things that say 9 degrees of
freedom sensor that means you get three
degrees of freedom from your
accelerometer three degrees of freedom
from your gyroscope and three degrees
the freedom from a magnetometer so it's
all combined in one one chip basically
now here in this next topic which is
inertial navigation we're gonna dip our
toes in the in the in the land of
perception basically so we're gonna if
you remember at the start of the chapter
I told you
one of the ways you can do localization
is via debt Reckoning right so you
basically integrate your uh trajectory
one step at a time so we're going to
look at that and uh and see how that is
done using inertial sensors that we
learned about again that Reckoning can
you can use different sensors to do that
you're going to look at the inertial
version of it basically okay
so this is called initial navigation and
it's as I said that Reckoning using
measurements from accelerometers and
Gyros
and there's a term for this called
inertial navigation system or ins so
what an ins is is basically it's a it's
your IMU which is an accelerometer and a
gyroscope plus a little bit of you know
uh extra compute in the form of like a
DSP processor on a microcontroller that
processes the signals from the gyroscope
and the accelerometers and essentially
does a little bit of uh that Reckoning
for you and gives you like trajectories
or positions and velocity so it kind of
integrates the outputs of these these
two sensors so that combined thing is
called ins or
inertial navigation systems so when it
comes to you know buying devices you can
buy just accelerometers or or gyroscopes
or the combined one which is axle gyro
or axle gyro magnetometer you can also
buy inss which does the processing of
the signals also for you and it kind of
does that little bit of perception for
you but we want to learn how to do that
from scratch so because there's a lot of
very important details and and how it
should be done properly so
for that Reckoning again the problem
statement is you have some robot some
vehicle something that is moving with
respect to a global reference frame
right which is fixed so we call that S S
Sub G so that's our fixed uh world
reference frame or the global reference
frame again it can point to fixed
geographical directions like North East
down or something like that and then you
have an ins on your robot which is
accelerometer gyroscope plus a little
bit of additional signal processing
the signals that you get out of your
accelerometer and gyroscope the device
has no idea about your world coordinates
right so it's going to report these
quantities which are accelerations and
angular velocities in its own reference
frame right so whatever like if this
blue box is your is your IMU it's going
to have its own XYZ coordinates we call
it S Sub B for the that's the body
reference frame of the device and the
values the device is going to report is
with respect to its own a reference
frame right so in order to be able to do
that Reckoning of course it's only
useful in in our Global reference frame
so we need to transform the readouts of
the device from its body reference frame
to the global reference frame before we
integrate those right so very concretely
let's say you have an accelerometer on
some vehicle and it's telling you you're
going in X Direction with an
acceleration of one meters per second
squared
but what is X Direction with respect to
geographical coordinates is it pointing
to the north is it South is it East is
it West is it something in between you
need to know that and then transform
that
readout from the body coordinates to the
global coordinates before you integrate
and do that Reckoning that's a critical
step that needs to be done okay
so uh because of that there's two
different types of inertial navigation
systems
uh one is called a stable platform ins
so stable platform ins what it does is
that uh it has what we call gimbals
which are these like it has like a
moving platform inside the device with
motors uh in it in in three axes and it
uses the readouts from the gyroscope and
as soon as it senses there is some
rotation being applied it corrects for
it so it always aligns your
accelerometers with the global
um basically external Global reference
frame right and it's doing that by
physically moving the device right so as
you can imagine the stable platform ins
has become these you know big clunky
things with multiple motors and gimbals
and things like that
and they're big they're expensive they
have you know a lot of limitations but
there also can be very very accurate so
for instance in spacecrafts and very
expensive airplanes these type of
accelerometers are used a stable
platform and by that basically
correcting for the the you know the
orientation of the device and always
aligning it with an external reference
frame you always basically you eliminate
the problem of having two different
reference frames because you always
actively align your sensor to the
external reference so your S Sub B which
is your body reference coordinates is
always equal to the global reference
coordinates right so that's a stable
platform
and uh let's let's see a quick movie of
of one of these because these are
fascinating things so so
um if this place yeah um before I play
it so so this is why it's it's this it's
a big thing it's almost the size of this
little stand that that I'm I'm using and
this is the one that is used in the in
in some fighter jets and I think a
version of this was also sent to the
moon on on the on the Apollo Mission and
here they're testing it so you would see
how so it needs to apply rotations in
three axes right so that it can correct
for yaw pitch and row and uh
and that's the thing uh you see you can
rotate in in three axes it can do it
very fast here you're just testing it
you really don't need the audio here but
you get the idea right I think this one
is called ln3 yeah ln32a
um so so it works uh and it does a very
good job with with aligning things
um but but it's also pretty clunky and
expensive and big
um cheap versions of of these you might
have seen like uh YouTubers around which
have these little gimbals with their
phone on it and it and it always kind of
you know it's like a little thing with a
handle and it always you know stabilizes
the phone to to to get rid of you know
vibrations and things like that those
work with the exact same principles so
they have basically Gyros inside and
there's a motorized Gimbal and it
stabilizes the thing and always aligns
it with the same external uh frame of
reference then we have a strap down ins
which uh which basically has has none of
these you know active control stuff so
it's exactly just one chip
um with with gyroscopes and
accelerometers inside and it has no way
of enough
correcting this basically uh uh the
discrepancy between the body reference
frame with the the global reference
frame mechanically so it has to be done
in Signal processing right and the stop
down ins is the one we'll study in
detail because uh that's that's the the
most common one and you know the types
of robotic applications that most likely
you would be dealing with
okay so when it comes to um
doing that Reckoning or inertial
navigation with these two different
types of systems let's look at the ins
the stable platform ins first so with
the stable platform ins
um you you basically again your
accelerometer is always aligned with
your Global reference coordinates so
it's very easy you just take the
accelerometer readouts you subtract the
gravity component right you should
always subtract the gravity component
because uh the the gravity component
that the device senses is actually
through contact so that's again if it's
like sitting on this table it's going to
sense a 1G pointing up and that's you
know just a balancing Force applied
through the contact to balance out the
the pool of of gravity so you always
want to subtract that out because that
doesn't cause any motion right so
subtract the gravity then you get
accelerations in in the global reference
frame you integrate once you get
velocity you integrate again you get
Global position very easy right so
that's stable platform it's not what
we're gonna study that's too easy for us
so we're going to look at strap down
would stop down what you do you need to
do a little bit of Sensor Fusion between
your gyroscope and and accelerometers so
from the gyroscope readouts uh which are
angular velocities uh if you integrate
those and we'll see how to integrate
them you can get essentially the
orientation relative to the global
reference frames and you use that
orientation information to transform
your accelerometer readouts from the
body frame to the global frame so you
apply this 3D rotation basically to your
exorometer readouts then you can
subtract gravity components and then you
get acceleration in the global reference
frame you can integrate once to get
velocity integrate again to get position
so essentially what this step does for
you transforming
which uses the gyroscope input right or
the integrated gyroscope input to apply
that transformation that is the
algorithmic equivalent of what a stable
ins does for you mechanically right so
the stable
ins just mechanically moves the thing to
align it in the strap down you apply a
rotation in math or in DSP or in
algorithms to do the alignment so the
end effect is the same you want to get
accelerations in the global frame and
then integrate those for basically to
get that Reckoning
okay
um
I'm not going to spend too much time on
this I think we talked about pros and
cons of both types of inss so again
stable platform big and clunky lots of
moving things it's also prone to
a bunch of very specific failures uh
there's a particularly bad one which is
called gimbal lock that you can look at
but that's the case where these three
gimbals get into this weird State and
then they cannot basically get out of it
and you need to reset the device
basically
um but the the uh what's good about it
is that your navigation algorithms are
extremely straightforward you just take
acceleration you know it's already
aligned to a global reference frame just
integrate it twice and that gives you
basically position
um but they're expensive and only used
and essentially like space and Military
applications
strap down devices are very very small
and cheap and reliable there's no moving
Parts no mechanical Parts tiny low power
but the trade-off is basically they
would need more complex algorithms to to
do this alignment of the body frame to
the global reference frame okay let's
just set up the problem real quick for
orientation tracking and then we'll
finish it next time together so again
with we're talking about strap down
inertial navigation and the first thing
you need to know do is you would need to
align the readouts of your accelerometer
to the global reference frame and to be
able to do the alignment you need to
know the orientation of your device you
need to know okay I'm pointing to
30 degrees with respect to geographical
North and if you know that orientation
then you can apply the inverse rotation
to align your measurements to the global
reference frame okay
so
uh to track orientation uh we use
gyroscope and gyroscope as we know it
gives you if it's a three axis gyroscope
it gives you three readouts right it
gives you angular velocities uh relative
to X Y and Z directions of the device
right so that's why there's a subscript
B here so these are measurements in the
body reference frame of of the device
right so that's your gyroscope readouts
and at a high level to track orientation
also called the attitude of the device
what you need to do the angular
velocities are the are the rates of
rotation right so if you integrate the
rate of rotation then then you should be
able to get the actual orientation or
the pose of the device so you basically
at a high level you want to integrate
Omega or the three components of the
Omega to find the orientation in the
global reference frame to do that you
need to parameterize uh the the problem
properly and there is different
parametrizations for orientation
tracking most common ones are Euler
angles is one there's quaternions and
there is Direction cosines and there's
you know mathematically I mean at the
end of the day they all are different
mathematical
parameterizations or representations to
solve the same underlying problem of
tracking orientation but it turns out
that with different formulations uh
there's you know pros and cons to how
you do the math I particularly like
Direction cosines and that's what I'm
going to use but you would see in
robotics for instance quaternions are
very common
Euler angles I don't recommend them much
because
there is a very specific you know
sources of confusion when it comes to
Euler angles there's nothing really
wrong with them but they're prone to you
know making making errors kind of so
we'll use Direction cosines and in our
formulation with with the direction
cosines specifically will work with uh
this Matrix we call C sub G and what C
sub G is it's a rotation Matrix that
basically so if you look at the two uh
reference frames one is the fixed for
world and one is your body
um the transformation between these two
is just a rotation right so if you find
the right rotation which we call Matrix
which we call C sub G and apply the
inverse of it to the to the uh body
reference frame it will rotate it back
and align it with the global reference
frame so in the 3D case your C sub G is
going to be a three by three rotation
Matrix and specifically what it's given
by is that its three columns are
basically the the three basis vectors of
your body frame of reference as
represented in the global reference
frame right so specifically if x sub b y
sub B and Z sub B are the the three axes
of your
body frame of reference your C sub G
this First Column is just X Hat B right
it's the unit Vector in the XB Direction
y Hat B and Z Hat B so this is the The
Matrix that we're trying to find using
um the readouts of the gyroscope and if
you can find this Matrix and it's going
to be a time varying Matrix right it's a
function of time because because we are
constantly rotating if you find that
then you can basically use that to
rotate back your accelerometer met
readouts to the global frame and then
from there it's just pure integration to
do dead reckoning okay so that's a
problem set up we'll solve it together
next time any questions
all right see you next time